bonjour jean marc sylvestre cette
question est une question récurrente en
france elle consiste à demander aux
entreprises des garanties de résultats
est ce qu'on peut attendre des
contreparties précise oui alors écoutez
vous avez raison de poser la question
parce que c'est compliqué cette affaire
à partir du moment où l'état développe
de l'argent public destiné à soutenir
l'économie à soutenir les entreprises il
est normal que l'état demande des
comptes et des engagements à ces
entreprises donc les syndicats sont dans
leur rôle quand il demande des
contreparties et le ministre et dans son
job quand il affirme qu'il discutera de
ses contreparties mais personne ne se
fait beaucoup d'illusions c'est en
général très compliqué c'est un plan
dette globale qui représente vous le
disiez 100 milliards sur deux ans et
donc beaucoup d'argent
l'essentiel de cet argent a d'ailleurs
été empruntés sur les marchés financiers
les marchés européens a également
il faudra donc que l'économie française
soit capable de rembourser ces prêts et
l'économie française est bien ce sont
les les entreprises c'est la première
des contreparties il faut donc attendre
que ce plan génère de la croissance
bruno le maire estime que normalement le
pays doit retrouver son niveau de
développement d'avant la crise
au début de 2000 29 ça fait donc encore
plus là non à attendre mais à ce moment
là on commencera à pouvoir rembourser
des dettes et à pouvoir respirer mais
quand les syndicats et l'opinion parle
de contreparties à il parle d'engagement
précis en termes d'emploi par exemple ou
d'environnement là ils sont issus
évidemment ce plan se compose voyez-vous
d'une série de mesures qui sont celles
dont certaines vont engendrer des
résultats qui seront faciles à chiffrer
facile à vérifier mais d'autres vont
être beaucoup plus compliqué et dont les
effets seront à long terme
premier point que l'état décide d'aider
la réindustrialisation des territoires
l'état va participer à des projets qui
seront très identifiés et très
contrôlable on va remonter une
entreprise là une usine ailleurs même
chose pour les aides à l'innovation pour
la transition numérique la
digitalisation on va débloquer 7
milliards d'euros
on aura quand même être capables de
savoir où il passe mais deuxième doit
quand l'état consacre 30 4 milliards
pour la compétitivité c'est déjà plus
compliqué
d'autant que dans ses 34 milliards vous
en avez plus du tiers qui passe par des
baisses d'impôts notamment les baisses
d'impôts de production si cette
compétitivité sert à créer de la
croissance
on le verra à créer des emplois on le
verra de ça marche mais sinon il y aura
un problème l état crée bien demander
des engagements de préservation
d'emplois mais pour les gros dossiers
c'est sans doute ce qui va se passer
chez renault c'est surtout ce qui va se
passer chez air france ou même à la sncf
j'ajoute la troisième fois c'est tout ce
qui concerne la transition écologique
qui est très importante politiquement va
être difficile à vérifier sur le court
terme
ça passe par des investissements par des
incitations par des pénalités donc le
résultat ne dépend pas seulement des
entreprises il est le papa de seulement
de l'état ça dépend j'ai des clients et
les clients n'ont aucune obligation
d'acheter le client est roi lui fait ce
qu'il veut regarder ce qui se passe dans
la voiture électrique
on a gavé le marché automobile au
lendemain du confinement avec des primes
des incitations de toutes sortes
on en a beaucoup parlé mais
l'automobiliste finalement écouté
regardé ce qui se passe il boude un peu
la voiture électrique pourquoi parce
qu'ils la trouvent pas encore assez
pratique assez économique et ça veut
dire que l'état aura du mal à imposer
des conditions
oui ça veut dire que tout le monde est
dans la même galère ça veut dire que
l'intérêt de l'état c'est évidemment que
ça marche
l'intérêt des entreprises c'est que ça
marche alors on a un premier scénario on
va retrouver au niveau macroéconomique
de la croissance donc des richesses donc
on retrouvera blank loi et finalement on
aura quelques satisfactions on pourra
alors même parler de transition
écologique parce qu'on aura les moyens
de la financer
il ya un deuxième scénario bien sûr
c'est qu'on ne retrouve pas trois sens
très vite et à ce moment là bien les
entreprises ne peuvent pas créer
d'emplois ne peuvent pas créer des
richesses et l'état ne pourra pas
rembourser par exemple son financement
il aura un problème de financement ça
veut dire que l'année prochaine sera
véritablement difficile à supporter à ce
moment là bien l'opinion demandera des
comptes elle demandera des comptes au
niveau social elle demandera des comptes
au niveau politique
elle demandera des comptes au niveau
financier en attendant en attendant il
va falloir avoir beaucoup de chance dans
cette affaire beaucoup de patience aussi
pour supporter les masques parce que
l'enjeu pour tout le monde
l'enjeu c'est de virus on voit bien ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui il faut
apprendre à vivre avec pour l'instant le
vernement les entreprises et des
syndicats sont quand même d'accord pour
considérer que cette contrainte et la
contrainte numéro un merci jean marc
sylvestre pour toutes ces précisions